one thing i like about android is that
enables you to build one application
that can adjust itself dynamic how two
different devices so and this is
possible because the UI is described in
xml and resources and the UI layouts are
packaged in a very smart way so when you
inflate the UI's from xml runtime itself
the flattering cell choose the best
layout from different screens so in that
way you can create only one application
package that will actually adjust itself
for different screen sizes different
color depth or just different devices
one thing I would like to see in on
Android is support for java native
interface in order to run some processor
expensive tasks in platform the platform
native language so in our case for
Shazam we create a fingerprints but for
right now we for our library to create
fingerprints is done is we use it on the
server side having a Jane I with enable
us to to make a fingerprint on the phone
and send less data to the servers